good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's hard to remember
now because history is pretty hazy but
it was just three years ago that joe
biden was considered too decrepit too
corrupt too out of touch ever to be
president and that wasn't just the view
from the right by the way they've mostly
stayed out of it that's what faithful
democrats were saying
in 2019 three separate neoliberal news
outlets the guardian the week and cnn
all published op-eds with the exact same
headline why joe biden shouldn't run for
president
other publications made the same point
with equal vehemence i really look like
joe biden but he shouldn't run for
president said a columnist for usa today
joe biden is not helping declared
rolling stone as if the goal was to help
and actually biden's family agreed with
this this is true they did not want him
to be president either some of biden's
closest relatives assured friends that
biden was running merely to work off the
grief from his son's death two years
before it made a kind of sense he needed
to get out on the road and clear his
head and a campaign was the way to do
that he knew he wasn't going to win
and for months it seemed all but assured
that he wouldn't win biden's first
debate performance in june was widely
written off as a disaster it seemed
pretty obvious he had zero chance at the
nomination
and then bernie sanders started to win
primaries for the second presidential
cycle in a row sanders proved to be the
only democrat in the field with
legitimate grassroots support
donors saw this and they panicked the
guy who hates billionaires what's he
going to do to wall street
so sanders was unacceptable to the
people who fund the democratic party but
there was a problem what were the
options
pete but a judge and beta o'rourke no
both it turned out to be lighter than
air
elizabeth warren double no
kamala harris was horrible on every
level absolutely nobody liked kamala
harris and for good reason
so it turned out to be joe biden by
default get off the biden signs we're
all in
and of course the media got the message
immediately by the time he was
inaugurated here's what the press corps
was telling you about joe biden
anybody who has any
connection to reality
about what is going on around them
should have watched that and said the
adults are back in the room it seems as
though we have a
a professional adult once again in the
white house who's just simply doing the
work really the the theme i would say is
the adults are back
still it is a relief
to have adults in charge now we have
adults in the white house okay the
adults are back in the room
there is a sense i think the world over
that the adults have returned we have an
adult in the white house now
and it's glorious
these people
never an original thought among them
he's an adult it's glorious
well half true biden is certainly an
adult he'll be 80 this fall
but no one in washington thinks the
biden presidency is glorious anymore
they think it's a disaster polls show
that voters strongly agree
joe biden is now the most unpopular
person in virtually any room he enters
if you doubt it watch this this was the
scene at the white house today take a
careful look at this you've never seen
anything like it
[Music]
that's the president united states in
his own house shunned
nobody would talk to him so biden
wandered off looking vacant as he
crowdformed around a former president
barack obama was obviously deeply
grateful for the attention and then it
got worse it got much more poignant than
that watch biden try to horn in on the
conversation swirling around obama
everyone involved in that conversation
including kamala harris supposedly works
for biden ignored biden completely
biden desperately tried to get obama's
attention he puts his hand on obama's
shoulder he even calls him barack like
they're friends
but obama blows him off he acts like
biden's not even there ask yourself if
you have ever in your life seen anything
sadder than this
[Music]
ah make it stop it's awful
now it's true that barack obama has
never liked joe biden for the eight
years they worked together obama mocked
him relentlessly as an old white guy he
did his best to keep biden at the
periphery that's why he got the ukraine
account
faithfully but even someone as arrogant
as barack obama can pretend if he has to
pretend and that's the point of the
video we just showed you obama no longer
has to pretend he can tell the world in
the clearest possible terms that he know
has no respect for joe biden because at
this point nobody has respect for joe
biden
even biden's most faithful supporters in
the press corps have turned on him watch
this
for president biden the outlook is
pretty grim
war abroad anxiety at home and inflation
at its highest level in 40 years sky
high inflation is erasing bigger
paychecks while hourly earnings are up
5.6 percent over last year nearly one in
five workers says they run out of money
before they get their next check you
have historic inflation you have record
gas prices americans are feeling it
biden's numbers have dropped by double
digits with young voters and they were a
big part of his coalition in 2020. voter
anxiety is about more than rising prices
or russia's war in ukraine
violent crime in american cities remains
persistently high and there is a growing
problem at the border president biden's
approval rating still hasn't found
bottom and it's been slowly trending
down all year
oh wait a second correction breaking
news it looks like inflation
is real it's not transitory it's
actually making us poor
crime and disorder in the cities are
real too and guess what it looks like a
totally pointless war with russia is not
as popular as we thought it was
you're not a traitor for not wanting it
all of a sudden they're admitting all of
this
for months biden's been telling us that
every bad thing you notice around you is
of course vladimir putin's fault and the
media have backed him up but suddenly
they aren't backing him up anymore
ready to be shocked again watch a group
of liberal toadies demolish the biden
white house's favorite talking point
here it is and every time we talk about
gas prices democrats who president biden
is always putin's price hike they're
trying to blame of course the russian
president and the invasion of ukraine uh
for the jump
in prices but of course as polling
suggests this president is going to take
a lot of the blame here biden has called
it a putin price hike but most americans
aren't buying it with the midterms now
just a few months away and inflation at
a record high the president is now
putting the blame squarely on vladimir
putin calling this the putin price hike
but his republicans and the president's
critics have been quick to note gas
prices were already rising before russia
started this war
the white house is trying to do
to do to both blame putin blame the oil
and gas companies but americans just
don't
agree what
no they tell us is your head spinning
yet yeah okay just one more
here's sandy cortez who has finally
turned on joe biden now it was just a
year a half ago that sandy's job was to
use all the street cred she'd earned
growing up in the leafy suburbs of
westchester and then heading off to
boston university to use all of that
urban credibility to convince the young
people that actually joe biden was okay
yeah he's old and white but go ahead and
vote for him anyway he's got sandy's
seal of approval
selling joe biden was her job and of
course she did it she's always been more
much more a dutiful party apparatchik
than a revolutionary
but not anymore
sandy cortez sees change coming if
there's one thing she's good at it's
knowing the prevailing wind
so she's happy to attack biden watch
this
we need to acknowledge that this isn't
just about
middle of the road an increasingly
narrow band of
of independent voters
but this is really about the collapse
and support among young people among the
democratic base feeling like they are
not that they worked overtime to get
this president elected and they aren't
necessarily being seen
oh so sandy's out
that means everyone's out what's going
on here well exactly what it looks like
the democratic party and his media wing
have decided to jettison joe biden there
was never an official order to do this
what you're watching here as always is
the hive mind at work democrats have the
same reactions because they have the
same instincts biden is weak we must get
rid of him
now to most people that sounds harsh and
unforgiving but in the animal kingdom
it's an entirely natural response it's
the first rule of dog packs for example
if a single dog wavers or lags behind
the other dogs will kill him even if
they're from the same litter yes it's
fracture side but it's nothing personal
it's a matter of group survival and
that's exactly how the democratic party
operates individuals are irrelevant to
the party the group is all that matters
no one at the dnc actually cares about
joe biden or ever has or for that matter
cares about george floyd or greta
thundberg or david hogg or anyone else
they tell you is an irreplaceable hero
all people are expendable
what matters is the party and the party
matters because in numbers there is
power
and of course on some level joe biden
knows this he spent his life in the
democratic party he's never worked
outside the democratic party so he
understands how this ends
inevitably after 50 years it is his turn
to be eliminated will he scream for
mercy like beria did or will he take it
like a man that's the only question
biden can't lead therefore at some point
soon he won't be allowed to lead
it's that simple and if you doubt it
watch biden talk sometime here's biden
the other day telling us that jill biden
was in fact once barack obama's vice
president
and i'm deeply proud of the work she's
doing as first lady with joining forces
initiative she started with michelle
obama when she was vice president and
now carries on
you know it feels mean even to play that
but it's not a unique example we see
examples like that every single day and
his fellow democrats see them too
so they've decided to replace joe biden
period but how will they do it and who
they replace him with
that's what we don't know subscribe to
the fox news youtube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from tucker carlson tonight